plus important que les années
précédentes le marché de noël de
villepreux a mis l'accent sur
l'artisanat vingt exposants venus pour
la plupart des yvelines ont présenté
leurs créations devant un public conquis
tout est fait main et en pièces uniques
ça c'est important c'est à dire que la
la la visite est la cliente elle peut se
dire ben y'a que moi qui ait ce produit
et là j'ai craqué effectivement là j'ai
acheté une petite pochette toile de jouy
très jolie qui est un ballet déjà mais
avec un plus que des pièces artisanales
unique
donc c'est plus agréable que dans la
grande distribution
un rendez vous important également pour
l'équipe municipale qui profite de ce
moment pour échanger avec les habitants
depuis 2008 on vient sur le marché de
manière très régulière pour rencontrer
les gens qui habitent ici c'est un
moment qu'on aime bien parce que les
gens viennent nous voir viennent nous
viens nous pas nous parler on se
retrouve ensemble avec tous les élus on
est une véritable équipe c'est aussi ça
notre force à villepreux des animations
pour toute la famille ont permis aux
plus jeunes de patienter une photo pour
le tabac noir et détient des quatre le
panneau avant l'arrivée dans quelques
jours du célèbre bonhomme à la barbe
blanche